[Music]
Arthur curry J Aquaman
so named Aquaman's wife how cool was it
to step into this whole DC Universe you
know I had no idea how fun it would be
really comic books are fun the
suspension of reality is is unparalleled
in this this genre is really just
there's nothing like it but what I
wasn't expecting more than anything is
the the joy of the fans the fans make
this genre everything the fans are fans
by the way love Jason
like the women are going nuts for him
what makes him so sexy what is it about
him I think Jason is as a great is a
great human he's a great person and and
and he was a I think he's gonna be a
great Aquaman also known as protector of
the oceans the Aquaman what was it like
shooting those scenes in the tank with
Jason and Nicole Kidman plays his mom II
mean what was it like working with her I
worked with so many great actors on this
movie Willem Dafoe Nicole Kidman and of
course Jason Patrick Wilson and the
director James Wan who's I'm a huge fan
of I think I was really lucky to get
that collaboration to get a chance to go
and step into this universe and it was
like you guys had a lot of fun shooting
in Australia lots of red wine involved
from your Instagram we had a lot we had
a lot of fun and and
and it was it was great we spent a lot
of time down there and it can be an
isolated place so you spent a lot of
time with your crew yeah yeah you got to
bring your phone with you as I said like
being in that tight costume I heard they
had to lay you against a wall in between
scenes it was so tight is that true I
did start with a leaning board that's
what it's officially called
but but I I adapted I learned how I
could sit and move and let's say I've
been a more comfortable clothes
[Music]
you
[Music]